alright ladies and gentlemen Justice
League let's get Zack Snyder to the
stage
Justice League director Zack Snyder
thank you for being here again sir
now yeah that's that's the intro this
work looks better than this one uh now
Zack I'm told that you have a little bit
of a surprise for us is that right well
I'm told if you you know it's it's good
to have you here and you want to bring
some people out is that running people I
like your ring good luck I will bring
them out but I thought you were gonna
say hey let's bring some people out hey
let's bring some people out now you guys
I'm sorry I'm a little delirious but we
were literally shooting the movie
backstay hey yeah we're backstage
shooting the movie was like cut okay run
else on stage let's get him out here
ladies and gentlemen
Ben Affleck whoo go get Oh ray Fisher
Ezra Miller and Jason Momoa
ladies and gentlemen the Justice League
haha I love Jason sad that is very go
Jason is touring with the Charlie
Daniels Band this summer no no no I mean
it's not I mean it's it look it's
Justice League its Justice League esque
or ish I mean traditionally I don't know
the Justice League has an additional
character but yeah but we all know that
character died he did up he died I saw
the only in the movie yeah well I mean
there was a small there was a I mean
look I don't want to ruin it or anything
but I mean you got to have Superman
now he's dead Campbell no what
yeah all right gotcha gotcha gotcha
we're good
I think you have a little something now
that you were we're all here now let me
get this right you you think that we
would show footage now now I would think
having these people here in person would
be enough yeah it seems less all you
need to do is have the people here you
would not need to show any footage I
mean we've only been shooting for a
while like to my eye are we shot a small
we cut together a teeny it's really just
a taste
but um yeah oh let me show it we should
show it let's give it up for the Justice
League
Justice League opens November 17th 2017
thank you all desire
you